police are investigating the sudden
death of a Cirque de Soleil performer
during a live show earless jaan Arno
fell to the stage during this
high-flying choreographed routine on
Saturday night in Tampa Florida he later
died from his injuries at the hospital
Toni to cope was following the
investigation Toni good morning was
tough to watch though yeah good morning
long painful weekend for a Cirque de
Soleil yawn Arno was a performer with
Cirque de Soleil for more than 15 years
and the company says Arno had practiced
this routine for two months but it was
only his second day executing it for a
live audience aerialist yawn Arno and
his partner had completed a series of
choreographed flips and spins before our
nose hand appeared to slip from the
strap causing him to plummet to the
stage below Taylor Avery was at
Saturday's show he looked like he hit
his neck or her shoulder and laid there
motionless and the paramedics during the
hospital Tampa Police say he fell 20
feet to the ground Arno had been with
Cirque de Soleil for more than a decade
most recently part of its touring show
Volta a production centered on extreme
sports Surt CEO Daniel Lamar says they
use safety nets and harnesses when they
feel they're appropriate but didn't feel
they needed them here we have been doing
straps in a lot of our shows for many
many years so far we never had a major
incident and therefore over the years
nobody thought that we needed to have
either a safety net or an honour this is
the second deadly fall during the live
Cirque de Soleil performance in 2013 31
year old Sarah we are we OH fell about
50 feet during a dramatic fight scene in
the Las Vegas show
Kaah CEO Lamar says he will review the
results of an independent investigation
to see if changes need to be made for
future shows but for now he says he's
focused on honoring Arno's legacy he was
a total demonstration of what circus all
about meaning trying to impress the
public traveling around the world
enjoying himself by doing the one thing
he loves to do in life the CEO says our
nose wife also worked for the show and
his Instagram appears to show two
children the final two perform
it says in Tampa were canceled next up
in New Jersey that's gonna be in ten
days but the company is saying
performers can take as long as they want
to in getting there yeah it's a reminder
that these are genuinely death-defying
stunts these are real performers yeah
spectators we assume that they're always
wearing harnesses and their safety nets
but in this case there wasn't big
question there why was there no net
actually the second time
honey thanks